Você está magro, seu MC está dentro do
normal e por isso você acha que
resistência insulina é problema de quem
está acima do peso. Você pode estar
redondamente enganado. Um estudo
publicado no Journal of Physiological
Anthropology em 2024 mostrou que até 45%
das pessoas com peso normal podem ter o
que os pesquisadores chamam de MONW,
metabolicamente obeso, peso normal, ou
seja, magro por fora, mas com o
metabolismo de quem está obeso por
dentro. E o pior, a maioria dessas
pessoas não faz ideia disso porque os
exames de rotina simplesmente não pegam
esse problema. Hoje eu vou te mostrar os
cinco sinais que denunciam essa condição
silenciosa. E acredite, o terceiro sinal
surpreende até médicos experientes.
Antes de mais nada, deixa explicar o que
acontece no corpo de quem tem essa tal
obesidade metabólica oculta. Veja bem, o
problema não é o peso na balança, o
problema é onde a gordura está
armazenada. Pessoas com peso normal
podem acumular gordura visceral, aquela
gordura que fica grudada nos órgãos,
especialmente no fígado e no abdômen. E
essa gordura visceral é metabolicamente
muito ativa. Ela libera substâncias
inflamatórias que bagunçam completamente
a sinalização da insulina. É como se
suas células deixassem de ouvir os
comandos da insulina, mesmo você sendo
aparentemente saudável. Um estudo
genético importante publicado na revista
Diabetes com mais de 40.000 1
participantes analisados encontrou algo
impressionante.
Pessoas que carregam certos genes de
resistência insulina são, na verdade
mais magras do que a média, mas tem
risco significativamente maior diabetes
tipo dois, doença cardíaca e
hipertensão. Ou seja, a natureza criou
um paradoxo. Ser magro geneticamente
pode vir junto com metabolismo
disfuncional. Agora vamos aos cinco
sinais que você precisa conhecer. Sinal
número um, trigliceridos elevados mesmo
com colesterol normal. Esse é um dos
marcadores mais confiáveis e mais
ignorados. Se os seus triglicerídos
estão acima de 150, especialmente se
estão acima de 100 em jejum, preste
muita atenção.
Os pesquisadores desenvolveram um índice
chamado TYG,
que é a combinação de triglicerídos com
glicose de jejum.
Esse índice se mostrou excelente para
identificar resistência à insulina
oculta. O estudo coreano de 2024
estabeleceu pontos de corte. Valores de
TYG acima de 8,88 para homens e 8,80
para mulheres indicam alto risco. Então,
anota aí, pegue o seu resultado de
triglicerídeos e glicose de jejum e peça
pro seu médico calcular esse índice.
Pode ser a diferença entre pegar o
problema no início ou descobrir quando
já virou o diabetes. Sinal número dois,
gordura abdominal desproporcional. Sabe
aquela pessoa que tem braços e pernas
finos, mas a barriga parece não
combinar? Isso tem nome. É o padrão de
distribuição de gordura central. A
circunferência da cintura é um preditor
muito mais importante que o peso. Para
homens, cintura acima de 94 cm já é
sinal de alerta para mulheres acima de
80. E tem mais, a relação cintura
quadril também conta muito.
Outro índice que está ganhando destaque
é o Vaii, índice de adiposidade
visceral. Ele combina cintura, índice de
massa corporal MC, triglicerídeos e HDL
colesterol. Então esse índice mostrou
sensibilidade acima de 80% para
identificar pessoas metabolicamente
obesas com peso normal. Sinal número
três, manchas escuras em dobras de pele.
Esse sinal surpreende porque muita gente
acha que é sujeira ou questão de
estética.
As manchas escuras no pescoço, nas
axilas, na virilha ou nos cotovelos tem
nome acantose níricans. E sabe o que
causa? Excesso de insulina circulando no
sangue. Quando você tem resistência à
insulina, o pâncreas produz cada vez
mais insulina para poder compensar.
Então esse excesso de insulina estimula
os melanócitos da pele a produzirem mais
pigmento, criando essas manchas
aveludadas, escurecidas. Se você notou
essas manchas aparecendo, especialmente
se você não é obeso, esse é um sinal
vermelho que não pode ser ignorado.
Sinal número quatro, fadiga e sonolência
após refeições. Sabe aquela sensação de
querer dormir depois do almoço? Todo
mundo sente um pouco, mas se isso é
intenso e frequente, cuidado. O que
acontece é o seguinte: quando você come
carboidratos e sua insulina não está
funcionando direito, a glicose sobe
rápido, o pâncreas dispara uma dose
cavalar de insulina e aí vem a
hipoglicemia reativa, a glicose despenca
e você fica exausto com fome de novo,
irritado, sem conseguir se concentrar.
Esse sobe e desce é chamado de montanha
russa glicêmica. Se você precisa de café
ou doce no meio da tarde para funcionar,
isso pode ser o seu corpo gritando que a
insulina não está trabalhando direito.
Sinal número cinco, dificuldade
persistente de perder gordura abdominal.
Você faz dieta, faz exercício, a balança
até desce um pouco, mas aquela gordura
teimosa na barriga parece que não sai de
jeito nenhum. Isso é clássico de
resistência à insulina. A insulina é um
hormônio de armazenamento. Quando ela
está alta cronicamente, seu corpo fica
em modo poupar gordura o tempo todo,
especialmente na região abdominal, que é
onde os receptores de insulina são mais
sensíveis. Um estudo de Singapura com o
fenótipo MONW mostrou que esses
indivíduos têm metabolismo de gordura
completamente alterado, com o corpo
preferindo guardar gordura ao invés de
queimar. É como se o termostato
metabólico estivesse travado. E o que
fazer se você se identificou com esses
sinais? O primeiro passo é entender que
você não pode ignorar esse problema só
porque a balança mostra um número
aceitável. A resistência à insulina
silenciosa é uma bomba relógio
metabólica. Com o tempo ela evolui para
pré-diabetes, depois diabetes tipo 2 e
de quebra aumenta drasticamente o seu
risco cardiovascular. Não é questão de
vaidade, é questão de saúde e
longevidade. Segundo, exija do seu
médico os exames certos. Não adianta só
a glicemia de jejum. Peça insulina de
jejum também para calcular o R. Esse
índice acima de 2,5 já indica
resistência à insulina significativa.
Peça hemoglobina glicada, ela mostra a
média de açúcar no sangue nos últimos 3
meses e se possível peça para calcular o
índice TYG que eu mencionei. Esses
exames custam pouco e podem revelar o
que está escondido. Terceiro, entenda
que a solução não está em remédios, está
em mudança de estilo de vida. A
restrição calórica moderada já mostrou
reverter o fenótipo MONW em estudos
clínicos.
Exercício resistido, ou seja,
musculação, melhora dramaticamente a
sensibilidade à insulina, porque o
músculo é o maior consumidor de glicose
do corpo e a qualidade dos carboidratos
que você come importa muito mais que a
quantidade. Trocar carboidratos
refinados por fibras e proteínas de
qualidade já faz uma enorme diferença
nessa montanha russa glicêmica. Aqui no
YouTube eu preciso simplificar e omitir
protocolos mais específicos. Sobre
resistência insulina, por exemplo, eu
não posso detalhar os protocolo de
experimentação que eu uso para
sensibilizar a insulina, nem as dosagens
específicas de berberina, cromo e
magnésio que fazem diferença real. Na
comunidade fechada eu compartilho tudo
sem filtro, protocolos exatos da
clínica, incluindo como combina um jejum
intermitente com suplementação
estratégica para reverter resistência
insulina mesmo em casos difíceis.
combinações que funciona, fornecedores,
interpretação avançada de exames, lives
semanais, PDF com 47 protocolos, grupo
no WhatsApp, clique em seja membro. E no
nível dois, a cada duas semanas, fazemos
imersões de 2 horas de secando artigos
científicos, como os estudos sobre
índice T yg e o fenótipo MONW, que
poucos médicos ainda conhecem, debatendo
controvérsas bastidores da ciência. Seu
nome aparece nos vídeos como
agradecimento. É o círculo interno de
quem quer ir além. Já que falamos de
resistência à insulina, você precisa
entender como magnésio afeta diretamente
a sensibilidade das suas células
insulina. Assista esse vídeo aqui sobre
os tipos de magnésio e deficiência
oculta, que vai complementar
perfeitamente o que você aprendeu hoje.
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube.
Começando pelos novos membros que
entraram recentemente, Walter Salgado,
Luciano Silva Polinelli, Luciano Elias,
Carlos Rovi, Odonor Pinheiro, Cíntia de
Assis Oliveira, Jorge Cabral e Fernando
Machado. Sejam muito bem-vindos.
Agradeço também aos membros que fizeram
upgrade por os estudos avançados. Irma
Carol e Ana Medicina, Adriane, Dra. Ana
Paulo Rodriges, José Fortunato Murtinho,
Sou Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mares, Eloterapias
Integrativas e Saúde, Luís Anselmo
Neves, obrigado pela confiança em elevar
o nível de participação. Um abraço
especial aos membros que retornaram à
comunidade, Alex Caldas, Marcelo
Pimentel e Cláudia Leitão. Que bom ter
vocês de volta. Quero fazer um
reconhecimento especial aos membros mais
fiéis. Estela Mares com incríveis 57
meses de fidelidade. Dr. Ana Paulo
Rodrigues com 45 meses de participação.
Marcelo Pimentel com 24 meses e
Eloterapias integrativas com 10 meses de
história conosco. A todos vocês eu
agradeço de coração pelo apoio prestado.
Vocês fazem a diferença nessa
comunidade.